Speaker 1: Well, before I get to a clip here from
MSNBC of Democratic Representative Maxwell Frost
talking about a proposal, a bill actually he's
introduced to create an Office of Gun Violence
Prevention. And a great idea. And all around,
we need more action specifically by Republicans
for them to get on board with common sense
solutions to gun violence, decreasing the
carnage we experience in America. Before I get to
that, though, we have seen yet another devastating
mass shooting. And this is what is being
responded to in the clip I'm about to show you
here from the Lexington Herald-Leader. A gunman
opened fire in a downtown Louisville bank Monday
morning, killing at least five people and
hospitalizing eight others. The Louisville
Metro Police Department confirms few details
have emerged, but by Monday afternoon about the
shooter or other victims. But emotional Governor
Andy Bouchard did say one of the deceased as.
Oh, my gosh. As a very close friend during a news
conference. Well, this is Kentucky's first mass
shooting of 2023. It's the 146 mass shooting
in the US just this year. That's according to
the Gun Violence Archive, 146 mass shootings just
this year. In America. And as I said in the last
segment on today's show, it is a multifaceted
approach to decrease gun violence to address
this problem. But you can't ignore one of
the primary components, which is the gun.
That is how we are set so far apart from other
countries. When comparing developed countries,
their gun violence, the reality of guns and the
regulation. And there's two ways that are clear
and present. An undeniable. Two ways that we are
very different from other developed countries.
The first is the amount and how unregulated our
guns are. And the second is how much gun mounts
we have. So you can connect the dots there.
And we don't have to be seeing this type of.
Devastation on such a regular basis. Here
is Democratic Representative Maxwell Frost
talking about his proposal for an
Office of Gun Violence Prevention.
Speaker 4: You need people who are forward
thinking, progressive candidates and thinking
about ways of how we're going to end gun violence
at every level of government. I actually just
introduced my first bill, which creates a
federal Office of Gun Violence Prevention,
which will help do just that work with municipal
cities, state governments and Congress to provide
recommendations and give the data that we need
to solve this problem holistically. But what
we will refuse is politicians who go in front of
cameras and say, Oh, it's going to happen anyway.
There's nothing we can do. If that is what you if
that's the energy you're bringing to this problem,
you don't belong in the seat of power. You
don't belong in a place where you represent the
people. Because every death is a policy failure.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So while it would absolutely be
something I'd support to set up an Office of Gun
Violence Prevention, it also should be noted.
While there is. Absolutely complexity to how
we go about solving this in another way. It's
simple in terms of what the next step has to
be, and the only way reasonably realistically,
we're going to address and decrease gun violence
in the United States is for the Republican Party
to change their stance on this. That's just the
reality. And so down the road, there are so many
fascinating and complex conversations about how
we go about generally addressing crime and gun
violence, mass shootings, all that. But the
next step has to be we implement common sense
gun regulation. And what's blocking that? The
Republican Party. Next moment from this interview.
Speaker 4: I think we're going to continue to see
it, that this youth voter turnout will continue to
rise. We've seen the past three cycles have
had wildly amazing youth turnout numbers,
and we're not done yet. You know, in 2020, we had
the highest youth voter turnout in the history of
our country, and half of Gen-z can't even vote
yet. Meanwhile, the Republican Party is focused
on changing the voters. And you know, there's
something wrong with your policies. The party,
when your path to victory is changing with
the voters and gerrymandering our maps to
hell. And that's what's going on right now.
It's anti-democratic. It's not democracy,
and it's not the freedom and liberty that the
party tends to hold up. The Republican Party
holds up as their banner True patriotism is loving
the people in the country. It's not just about
the flag. It's about the people in the country.
And it's something that this generation, Gen Z
and young folks understand. And that's why we're
going to continue to fight. We will vote, but we
also will hit the streets and we also will take
care of one another. And I think that holistic
interpretation of what a movement is is part of
the reason why young folks are going to really
build political power quickly in this country.
It's using every single tool in our toolbox.
Speaker 1: So, uh, I really do like that line
of true patriotism is loving the people in
the country. It's not just about the flag, it's
about the people in the country. And I think that
highlights. What we'll see from.
Many within the Republican Party
this. This insistence on focusing on things
that are much more symbolic than they are.
Actually impacting people in their day to
day life. And that is why in large part they
distract with a lot of these are referred
to as culture war issues, things that are
vague and are abstract enough and symbolic enough
where you can get people riled up about it but
not actually be held to any standard. It's not a
tangible promise that you can be held to. And his
example of true patriotism being about the people
and not about the flag. It's great to. Have the
flag as a representation of our country and all
that. But when patriotism to you is just symbolic,
it's just wearing the flag. It's just. Whatever
it might be your. The way you go about saying the
Pledge of Allegiance and hand over heart and all
of that and all of it can be great and wonderful.
But let that let's make sure that's not a
replacement for what is actual patriotism,
which is fighting for the improvement of
the lives of people within the country. And
David has recently talked about someone I think
wrote into the show or called him on the show
and talked about how Republicans are able to
kind of co-opt these terms, these positive terms,
patriotism, and that is theirs or even the flag,
an American flag being a Republican thing often,
which is strange. It's all of our flag.
But it it definitely happens. The branding,
the messaging within the Republican Party
often is more effective, if even if dishonest.
And I think those on the left need to work
harder to make sure we don't just allow the
conversations to always be on their turf,
because no, I don't think it's patriotic to
spend all your time focusing on your obsession
with. You know your guns in and vag shirt
instead of focusing on protecting children
in schools based on common sense solutions.
And I don't think it's patriotic to allow. So
many people to be in poverty in this country and
not getting enough in the proper food. And we
could list off the racial inequality that we have,
the rolling back of rights for women that
we're seeing. And on and on it goes. That's not
patriotic to me. If you really loved your country.
You would love the people in it. And if you really
loved your country and the people in it, then you
would want to solve problems facing those people.
Seems pretty clear to me. But obviously a lot
of people don't buy into that. And it's all
about the songs and the flags instead
of the people. Much more after this.